ten thousand dollars i don't know how to
put this but it's kind of a big deal
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money ten
large is the tipping point between
living paycheck to paycheck
and financial freedom so you're either
striving to reach the 10k mark
or you have fond memories of the first
time you add 10k
to your name i remember being 26
broke as a joke i hustled in my sales
job for a solid
year and got my first big commission
check for ten thousand dollars
it was liberating so what does 10k
mean 10k is an emergency fund in the bad
times
and a cushion in the good times the
emergency fund is if you lose your job
and the cushion
allows you to decide what job is worth
your
time time is money and now you got
options someone offers you a job you
don't like you can say
no you're safe and liquid and you have
flexibility
and that's a beautiful thing 10gs also
builds confidence
and swag you can buy around at the bar
no
problem and you're not splitting any
checks on dates
10k allows you to go from a paycheck
mentality to a net worth mentality
net worth that's the name of the game
and don't rush it net worth comes with
age
the median net worth for someone under
age 35
is 14 000 age 35 to 44
is 90 000 45 to 54
is 170 000 so basically as long as you
keep working
saving and investing your net worth will
go up
because building wealth is a game of
adding zeros
first you get to a thousand then ten
thousand then a hundred thousand
then a milli but the first big mountain
to climb
is 10k and if you have 10k in your bank
account
you're more special than you think
according to data from the fed
american households have a median
balance of 5300
in their bank accounts and get this 25
percent of americans
have no savings whatsoever 65
live paycheck to paycheck 70 have less
than a thousand dollars in savings
and 90 are buying things they can't
afford
which brings me to my two cents
no you're lame if you're trying to get
to 10k you're gonna need to make some
serious
sacrifices your buddy asks you to spend
500 bucks at the club
sorry bro i want to be rich your
girlfriend is like oh let's go to
cabo it's only 3k don't be afraid to say
ah sorry baby i'm still building nike
comes out with a shoe that can tie its
own
laces and track the temperature of your
feet
you don't need them 10k
is like the admission fee to be able to
enter the investing roller coaster
you need to be this tall to ride you
shouldn't invest
unless you have 10k saved up and you
should stop
investing once your cash reserves go
below 10k
it works both ways that's the neutral
territory
once you get there there is a clear path
to wealth 100k
is right around the corner if you play
your cards right but you can't get there
if you don't have a savers mentality
saving
is the key to wealth and anyone can do
it all you got to do
is save that money
thank you for watching this video on the
importance of ten thousand dollars let
me know in the comments below
what 10k would mean to you and as always
save that money all we talk is money